IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY, AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
BREAKING NEWS ON THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN REPORTEDLY TELLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST WEEK THAT
HE IS NOT A TARGET OF ANY
PARTISAN SPECIAL COUNSEL
INVESTIGATION OR THE
INVESTIGATION INTO HIS LONGTIME
LAWYER MICHAEL COHEN.
THE LATEST DEVELOPMENT SURE TO
BE SEEN AS GREAT NEWS BY THE
PRESIDENT WHO JUST RAILED
AGAINST THE INVESTIGATION AS A
"HOAX."
>> THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION WITH
RUSSIA OTHER THAN BY THE
DEMOCRATS.
THIS WAS A, REALLY A HOAX
CREATED LARGELY BY THE DEMOCRATS
AS A WAY OF SOFTENING THE BLOW
OF A LOSS.
THIS IS A HOAX.
AS FAR AS THE INVESTIGATION,
NOBODY HAS EVER BEEN MORE
TRANSPARENT THAN I HAVE.
>> Kimberly: MOMENTS AGO
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
WEIGHED IN ON THE NEWS.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
IT'S A FAIRLY STANDARD PART OF
ANY LITIGATION, TRYING TO DECIDE
WHETHER A PERSON YOU ARE
ENCOUNTERING IS A WITNESS,
SUBJECT, OR TARGET.
A TARGET OF SOMEONE ON WHOM THE
INVESTIGATION, THE GRAND JURY
HAS DEVELOPED SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE, EVIDENCE OF VISIT TO
CHARGE FOR.
WITNESS HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
EXPOSURE.
A SUBJECT IS EVERYBODY IN THE
MIDDLE.
I DON'T KNOW THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL DID THAT BUT
THAT'S THE GENERAL FRAMEWORK.
>> Kimberly: ANOTHER EPISODE
OF SHAKESPEARE IN THE PARK
STARTING JAMES COMEY.
JESSE, HE IS A THOUGHTFUL GUY.
POETRY IN MOTION HERE.
WANTS TO WEIGH IN ON EVERYTHING
TO SELL A COUPLE BOOKS.
>> Jesse: YEAH, AND HE WILL
SELL BOOKS BUT I THINK IT'S
TIME'S UP.
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY SICK OF
JAMES, BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
BE SICK OF HIM WHEN HE'S ON
FOX NEWS.
WE WILL TUNE IN TO SEE
BRET BAIER TEAR HIM APART.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATIONS
LASTED ALMOST TWO YEARS.
IT'S GONE ON LONGER THAN THE
9/11 COMMISSION.
THEY'VE HAD MULTIPLE PEOPLE FROM
TEAM TRUMP TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF
THE HOUSE AND SENATE, SOME THREE
OR FOUR TIMES.
THEY TURN OVER OVER A MILLION
DOCUMENTS.
THEY FOUND NO COLLUSION.
IF THERE WAS A SMOKING GUN OF
COLLUSION, IT WOULD'VE LEAKED
BECAUSE EVERYTHING ELSE DOES.
THERE ARE NO CRIMES THAT WE HAVE
SEEN SO FAR, SO I DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING FOR.
YOU KNOW WHO HASN'T EVEN
TESTIFIED IN FRONT OF MUELLER?
BRAD PARR SCALE, TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN MANAGER, HEAD OF THE
DIGITAL MEDIA STRATEGY.
HE'S NEVER BEEN BROUGHT INTO
BEING INTERVIEWED.
WHAT IS MUELLER DOING?
I GUESS THEY APPROVED THIS RADON
COHEN FOR CAMPAIGN FINANCE
VIOLATION.
THAT'S A FINE.
BERNIE SANDERS PAID 14 GRAND FOR
TAKING MONEY FROM AUSTRALIANS.
YOU DON'T RATE SOMEBODY FOR A
CAMPAIGN FINANCE VIOLATION.
I THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO FLIP
AND SQUEEZE COHEN BECAUSE THEY
THINK HE MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING
BASED ON THE DOSSIER.
HE WAS THE CENTERPIECE OF THE
DOSSIER.
THEY SAID IT WAS PRAGUE READING
WITH RUSSIANS -- MEETING WITH
RUSSIANS.
HIS PAST FORCES IS NEVER BEEN TO
PRAGUE.
I DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE COLLUSION,
HILLARY WAS THE ONE WHO PAID FOR
FAKE NEWS FROM RUSSIA SHE WAS
THE ONE THAT GOT IT INTO THE
BLOODSTREAM OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
IT WAS HER HUSBAND WHO TOOK A
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS TO SPEAK
IN MOSCOW, NOT TRUMP'S SPOUSE.
IT WAS HER FOUNDATION THAT TOOK
MILLIONS FROM THE RUSSIANS, NOT
TRUMP'S FOUNDATION.
THE FBI DID NOT GO AFTER THE DNC
SERVER.
THEY DID NOT TRY TO SEIZE
HILLARY'S SERVER.
INSTEAD, THEY TRIED TO SEIZE
TRUMP'S LAWYERS' COMPUTERS.
THEY RESPECTED HILLARY'S
ATTORNEY-CLIENT PRIVILEGE BUT
NOT TRUMP.
HUGE DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> Kimberly: JESSE RESTS HIS
CASE.
KENNEDY.
DO YOU CONCUR OR SUPPLEMENT WITH
AN AMICUS BRIEF?
>> Kennedy: HERE'S A COUPLE
DIFFERENT THINGS HAPPENING.
EITHER THIS IS A WAY OF HAVING
THE PRESIDENT LET DOWN HIS GUARD
SO HE AGREES TO TALK WITH THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL AND COOPERATE
WITH THE INVESTIGATION SO THEY
CAN SNARE HIM IN SOME SORT OF
PERJURY TRAP.
PUSH THE BOUNDARIES AND FIGURE
OUT WHETHER OR NOT A SITTING
PRESIDENT CAN BE CHARGED FOR
SOMETHING.
OR THE INVESTIGATION IS ACTUALLY
WINDING DOWN AND PEOPLE WILL
FIND IT'S BEEN A BIG WASTE OF
TIME AND MONEY.
I THINK IF THAT TRULY HAPPENS,
THERE WILL BE SO MUCH
FRUSTRATION.
IT'S WORSE FOR THIS SITUATION WE
ARE IN NOW WITH THE FBI AND DOJ.
THERE IS SUCH AN EROSION OF
TRUST.
IF YOU HAVE POLITICIZED BODIES
WHICH ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
OBJECTIVE GOING AFTER PEOPLE TO
BRING THEM DOWN BECAUSE THEY
AREN'T HAPPY WITH THE OUTCOME OF
AN ELECTION, WHAT DOES THAT SAY
ABOUT THE STATE OF GOVERNMENT
WHEN YOU CAN'T EVEN TRUST AN
OBJECTIVE SOURCE?
>> Kimberly: I KNOW.
TYRUS, WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
NICE TO SEE YOU.
>> Tyrus: HI.
MAN, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WHEN I LOOK AT MY LIFE AND EVERY
TIME I'VE BEEN IN TROUBLE WITH
THE LAW WHICH HASN'T BEEN A LOT
BUT WHEN IT HAS, THEY SAY YOU
ARE NOT SUBJECT OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
I AM NOT TALKING ANYMORE.
MAY I GO?
THAT'S HOW THE PRESIDENT NEEDS
TO TREAT IT.
I'M NOT THE SUBJECT, COOL.
MOVE ON.
FOCUS ON THE OTHER STUFF.
IT'S NOT ME.
WHOEVER THEY ARE LOOKING FOR,
ENJOY IT BUT AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED IT'S DONE.
>> Kimberly: DON'T BE LURED
INTO THE MOUSETRAP.
>> Tyrus: IT'S A GREAT DAY.
IF YOU TELL ME I'M NOT A TARGET,
I DON'T HAVE TO TALK TO YOU
ANYMORE AND WE CAN MOVE ON.
>> Kimberly: NO SOUR GRAPES?
JUAN COME HE SHOULD LET IT GO?
>> Juan: HE HAS BEEN TOLD HE
WAS NOT A TARGET BEFORE.
>> Kennedy: EXACTLY.
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECT
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJEC
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECO
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECA
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECT
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECR
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECE
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJECT
HE WAS THE         WAS A SUBJEC.
>> Juan: THE POINT IS HE'S NOT
A TARGET.
HE CAN TURN INTO A TARGET.
HE DOESN'T HAVE A WHOLE LOT OF
SIGNIFICANCE IN THAT REGARD FOR
THIS INVESTIGATION.
I WAS SO FASCINATED LISTENING TO
JESSE.
SOMETIMES I LISTEN TO JESSE AND
I THINK, JESSE IS THE POET OF
TRUMP-LANDIA.
YOU CAPTURE THE PRESIDENT'S
VOICE.
>> Jesse: I AM GLAD YOU ARE
LISTENING TO ME.
A LOT OF TIMES IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE IT.
>> Juan: I LISTEN.
YOU ARE MY INSIDE SOURCE,
BROTHER.
I LISTEN TO YOU.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU ARE
LISTENING BUT YOU ARE NOT
HEARING.
>> Juan: I HEAR.
SOMETIMES I THINK G, I WONDER,
LET'S SAY PAUL MANAFORT IS
WATCHING "THE FIVE."
HOW ABOUT MICHAEL FLYNN?
I BET HE WATCHES "THE FIVE."
HOW ABOUT GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS?
THEY WOULDN'T SAY THAT NOTHING
HAS COME OF THIS INVESTIGATION.
THEY WOULD SAY MY GOD.
I MIGHT BE GOING TO JAIL.
>> Jesse: HE HAS A FIVE PAGE